kaley cuoco and carl cook are tying the
knot he is totally the guy after a year
and a half of dating professional
horseback rider Carl cook popped the
question to the Big Bang Theory star on
Thursday which also happened to be her
32nd birthday Carl shared this video of
a super emotional Kaylie on Instagram
that's on your finger the ring is
absolutely stunning
Carl posted a photo of the pear-shaped
sparkler designed by nnedi Steinman's
the night was also full of surprises
Kaylie was teary-eyed as she gave her
social media followers a peek inside her
romantic birthday dinner guys surprised
me tonight but I'm still I'm so touched
the greatest guy ever earlier this month
ET spoke with the actress she revealed
the secret to their long-lasting
relationship I think the common
denominator is the horses it just works
for us you know we have this special
bond and yeah the animals and he he's as
real and he's so real I've never met a
kinder human being he's gentle and he's
real and I'm completely in love with him
nothing could be better
[Music]